I'm kanpai
Dean of the Graduate School I'm a
biologist and welcome to our series for
2014 the company of scholars lectures
which is a series of lectures that the
Graduate graduate school sponsors to
provide to the community some lectures
of general interests on many different
topics David Evans our speaker today was
known to me as a fabulous University
citizen because I knew him from
promotions committees and other virtuous
activities that he was engaged in and
then suddenly a couple of years ago he
had this very high-profile paper in
nature that got in the newspaper and so
on and it I was suddenly aware of the
very very interesting work he was doing
doing that which he's going to talk
about today because I think we all know
that the continents have been drifting
around on the surface of the earth but
what he and his friends managed to do is
figure out where they're headed
which is pretty pretty interesting and
because there's gonna have a big impact
on all forms of life on on earth as
you'll hear in the lecture so this is
the first of three lectures we're having
the second one is by Susan hide from the
political science department which is on
March 25th she does research on on
Elections and her topic is going to be
does democracy promotion promote
democracy interesting question and then
Gary Tomlinson who's sitting right back
here it's going to speak on the 16th of
April about 1 million years of music
which sounds like another fascinating
topic looking back in time like our
speaker today and perhaps forward I
don't know okay.i David is the Yale
College graduate and got his PhD at
Caltech and did a postdoc in Australia
where he was working on some of the same
things he's talking about today I
believe he joined our faculty here in
the department of geology and geophysics
in 2002 and was promoted to associate
professor in 2007 and full professor in
2009 and you can see his title before
you David welcome
thank you very much for coming today I
will be stepping away from the podium so
I hope you can hear me in the back good
excellent and I imagine that a catchy
title such as this as this may have
drawn more of a broad crowd in Yale and
I hope that's the case and I hope to
intrigue you not only for the portion of
my research which will occupy the middle
of the talk the first two thirds of the
talk but also some speculations here at
the end on what a geologists not all
geologists but a geologist perspective
mine on the ultimate fate of humankind
so we are going to begin actually with
some audience participation and I'm very
curious what your views are in terms of
where humanity will be fifty thousand
years from now and so if you have an
internet mobile device you can go to
this website Paul M comm slash majestic
or you can text to two three three three
and submit your answer to this
multiple-choice question there is no
right answer
this is far in the future but where do
you think humans will be fifty thousand
years from now we have various options
we have natural extinction at the top
the first four extinctions the last two
are survival net of the votes are coming
in natural extinction which might be a
meteor impact or a supernova blast or a
pandemic disease we have man-made
extinction maybe nuclear holocaust
we have extinction or transmutation by
religious apocalypse think the Second
Coming if you will
conquest or annihilation by
extraterrestrial civilizations and then
the last two are what I imagine very
very broadly what a possible maybe
optimistic scenario might be would we
have a sustainable existence that's
confined to earth and perhaps just the
inner solar system the rocky planets the
Moon and Mars but maybe just earth or
the Star Trek's solution which is
expansion into deep space so I'll give
you a minute or two to register some
more votes if you are joining us
from the cyberspace the Tiber universe
on the streaming euro votes should also
count here so as I watch some more votes
come in we have more of a pessimistic
crowd perhaps in the audience today a
few more optimists coming in but what's
interesting is that I when I tried this
on my students in geology class I'm
teaching now I got a lot of questions
about what about global warming and will
that do you consider that to be natural
or man-made actually I left that up to
the the audience I think you will find
maybe I'll come back to that issue
personally I don't think global warming
is capable of causing the human
extinction it might make us very
uncomfortable okay so this poll will
continue to go on and we have more
optimists and we have somewhere between
a confinement to sustainable existence
on earth and the Star Trek solution
registering there so I'll return to this
at the end and register some of my
opinions as they come in so put this in
the background and click it out and here
we go
so the talk will be in three parts first
I am going to introduce to many of you
I'm swimming no prior advanced knowledge
in geology I'll give an introduction to
geology and what we call deep time
millions of years or billions of years
in the past and then that will segue
into my research which is the past in
the future motions of continents across
the Earth's surface using the magnetism
of rocks and then finally we'll get will
return to this subject of perhaps the
ultimate fate of humankind so to begin
with I will start with the concept of
deep time and walk you through some of
the most important events in the history
of Earth and life on Earth from our
perspective and so the concept of deep
time is one where you have to imagine a
time scale and the time scale can be
shown vertically or horizontally you'll
see both in this talk but vertically it
extends from the bottom and geology we
think of layers of
recording events in Earth history so
from the very bottom 4600 million years
ago the creation of the solar system
moving all the way up geological time
and the evolution of land plants and
reptiles and birds and dinosaurs so
finally humans up to the very top and
this kind of figure is what you might
find in any introductory geology
textbook or many popular websites but
notice that the timescale that's
employed is nonlinear and what that
means is that most of Earth history 88%
of Earth history in fact is shoved down
here at the bottom because frankly we
don't know a whole lot about it relative
to how much more information we have
from the relatively recent geological
past and if we were to plot things
appropriately in a linear time scale
that 88 percent of geological time which
is known as the Precambrian that means
prior to the Cambrian radiation of
animal life on earth this huge window of
time is really my playground for
research because there is recent
technological innovations which have
opened up the possibility of doing the
research that I do in Precambrian time
and what I hope to show you is that a
lot of our natural resources and
particularly our metal resources come
from Precambrian rocks and so part of
the industrial society and the excellent
lifestyle that we enjoy right now is
based on a long history of processes
that occurred in this time which until
relatively recently was somewhat
mysterious to us so let's start from the
very beginning and a little eye candy
for you a simulation of the moon-forming
impact shortly after the initial
accretion of the earth and a companion
body about thought to be about the size
of Mars that collided and ended up
ejecting a whole lot of material from
both bodies much of which got fragmented
and much of it was recreated to a very
glowing hot earth proto planet some of
it accreting in waves and what you don't
see in this image is the moon coming out
at
20 Earth radii away and forming from
that initial event so there's various
ideas in current research about how this
may actually have happened but the giant
impact theory is really the birth date
of effectively the earth as we know it
fast forward 1 billion years 1,000
million years from that event and we
find the oldest tangible of evidence of
life on Earth and it's a very humble
evidence at that these are called
stromatolites and they are found in
places such as Western Australia and
South Africa two of the oldest
well-preserved areas on our planet from
this age 3.4 G a and G stands for Giga a
stands for annum so a billion years ago
3.4 billion years ago we have the
suggestion that biology contributed to
making these conical layers and conical
structures in the rocks and then there
is some debate of course about whether
these are truly biological if there is
any scientific consensus it is based on
the comparison broadly between these
forms and similar forms today either in
the sub in the Bahamas underwater or as
you can see if you drive a full day's
drive north of Perth Western Australia
where I did my postdoc you can go to
Shark Bay and you can see these noble
and humble creatures building these bio
of cyanobacterial mounds in the shallow
sea so this is the suggestion of the
oldest life on Earth at about a billion
years after the formation from there we
can continue on with the Tree of Life
and the Tree of Life
as many of you know if you're biologists
has great three great super kingdoms
those of the eukaryotes which include
animals plants and fungi as well as
protists those of the bacteria and those
of archaea which were thought to be
bacteria for a long time until it was
realized that that archaea are as
different from bacteria as we are but
they are single-celled and various
estimates based on geological chemical
markers in that are preserved in
sedimentary rocks suggest the various
ages for nodes of branching along the
Tree of Life
we finally get up to animals here and
there we are that of course we place
ourselves at the top of this tree next
to our closest evolutionary relatives
which are mushrooms and corn so this I
hope gives you some perspective on the
diversity of life on earth and how small
we multicellular creatures are in that
kind of context another very very
important event fast-forwarding again
another billion years in this case now
we're looking at a timeline which goes
from four-and-a-half billion years ago
to the present and we're looking at a
plot of estimates of oxygen in the
atmosphere and today we have about 20%
oxygen in the atmosphere it's what we
breathe to survive but there was about
the first half of Earth history when
oxygen levels were vanishingly low and
this is a logarithmic scale so each tick
is 1/10 less a 10% of the tick above it
of the oxygen concentration so here we
are at present with about 20%
atmospheric oxygen but you go back about
a half a billion to a billion years and
you might be looking at 1% of that
fraction and before that even less and
obviously advanced life as we know it
ourselves could not exist without the
evolutionary innovation of oxygenic
photosynthesis within within within the
life the life's domain to produce oto as
a waste product and then the rest of
life had to respond to this abrupt rise
so this is one of the major events in
life history now we go forward another
billion and a half years and we get to a
concept which is called snowball earth
and snowball earth is the concept and
the hypothesis which is gaining support
through the years I think which is that
the earth on at least two occasions and
perhaps as many as five occasions around
600 to 800 million years ago completely
froze over and froze over for as long as
a few million years at a time life would
have a needed to exist we know because
we have the antiquity of of the of the
fossils with extant microbial organisms
where life would have had to exist under
the ice but it was very
very extreme challenges and in fact some
of the research that I do on the
magnetism of rocks gives us indications
that some of the ice deposits in these
times we're close to the equator of the
earth and by inference the entire Earth
should have been covered but that would
be a separate talk in itself or perhaps
even a semester course on the snowball
earth hypothesis what I'm hoping to do
just now is give you these insights
these little snapshots and important
evolutionary events in Earth history
from a biological perspective from the
moon-forming impact to the oldest
tangible evidence of life in the
stromatolites to the rise of oxygen to
these globally engulfing ice ages these
all set the stage for the Cambrian
radiation of animals that happen
abruptly about 540 million years ago now
if we were to truly appreciate this
amount of time the four billion years of
Earth history prior to the Cambrian
radiation of animals I find it
instructive to make an analogy with a
calendar year so if we begin a calendar
year on January 1st we get to June
before we have the oxygenation of the
atmosphere we get to mid-november before
we have the Cambrian radiation of
animals and you can see these various
other events which occurred in a more
recent geological time all basically
happening in December the large coal
swamps on dastaan the 1st of December
the largest extinction the
permian-triassic boundary 250 million
years ago by this calendar analogy is on
December 11th the dinosaur extinction on
Boxing Day the day after Christmas and
then finally humans come along at if you
include our australopithecines ancestors
as nominally human they show up at about
8-10 p.m. on New Year's Eve in fact all
of civilization let's let's be generous
and give ourselves 8,000 years of
agrarian society that the technology
that we use to become an agrarian
society do things like control yeast to
ferment alcoholic beverages that
technology was invented 55 seconds
before midnight perhaps just in time you
might say okay so with that introduction
to broad expanses of geological time
I'm going to shift gears and tell you a
little bit about the dynamic motions of
the Earth's surface and interior and to
appreciate that we have plates on the
earth we can find this animation of
earthquakes happening within a three and
a half decade interval from the latter
half of the last century and this is
just passive recording and location from
a series of seismic networks around the
world of where the earthquakes are
happening and as time moves on it
becomes clear that the earth is the
earth surface is divided into a series
of internally mostly rigid plates where
there are no earthquake epicenters
separated by relatively narrow zones of
lots of earthquakes and this is the
surface expression of motions in the
interior of the earth which are helping
the planet release its heat to space and
again it's a fascinating subject in
itself but for my purposes I'm
interested in tracking the long-term
history of the motions of those
continents as allowed by the presence of
these plate boundaries that allow the
relative motion of these large tectonic
plates which are internally rigid so
this is where how a geologists would
look at the map of the world and see the
plate boundaries each plate is shown in
a different color some plates are
entirely oceanic in character some
plates have carry continents with them
and notice that the edge of the
continent is not necessarily a plate
boundary as we have for example right
here in Connecticut so for this reason
we don't have major earthquakes where we
are at the edge of this side of the
continent and yet California and Alaska
have earthquakes at the edge of that
side of the continent because that side
of the continent coincides with a
tectonic plate boundary so with that
introduction to the Earth's system both
in time and space I can now tell you a
little bit about my research I'm sure
many of you have heard about the
supercontinent known as Pangaea which
broke apart started to break apart about
200 million years ago at that time
the time initial time of breakup a
position that's close to us here in
Connecticut was within perhaps a long
journeys walking distance from Morocco
in the Western Sahara and sorry when in
the last 200 million years we had a rift
system that spread North America away
from Africa and in doing so opened up
the Atlantic Ocean and carried us
farther and farther away not only from
our initial counterpart position in
Morocco but also far and far away from
this tectonically active mid-ocean ridge
thereby allowing us to live in a
tectonic lee quiescent environment today
so but this this kind of animation is
it's it's actually relatively easy to do
and it was first out in the 1960s and it
was made possible because of magnetic
variations that were observed by ships
towing magnetometers across the surface
of the ocean and we could as soon as we
understood the structure of the ocean of
the sea floor of the ocean basin we were
able to in a sense replay the movie
backwards and draw this new ocean
lithosphere back down the ridge to go
backwards in time so this the solution
of the Pangaea puzzle is a relatively
simple one by tectonic terms and to give
you a sense of of the kind of geological
structures that that rifting has left
behind in Connecticut for for your local
amusement we can look at the geological
map of Connecticut which was most
recently compiled by a very famous Yale
geology professor named John Rogers and
what you see in here are every color
represents a different rock type across
the state and so you can go from one
place to another and you can draw a map
and you know where you are and you find
a rock type that's that's distinctive
and you plot your position on the map
and you can trace these rock types
around and the red in this case
corresponds with igneous rocks these are
typically volcanic rocks and they are
associated without tearing apart of the
crust to
million years ago such rocks include
west rock and east rock and sleeping
giant and the hanging hills of Meriden
these are direct products of that
tearing a part of the crust 200 million
years ago they are embedded within a
series of sedimentary rocks that were
formed in a Great Rift Valley so if you
imagine what Connecticut was like 200
million years ago you can think about
going to East Africa today and seeing a
big Rift Valley pulling apart on either
side of the central Rift Valley we have
what we call the the western highlands
of Connecticut and the Eastern Highlands
of Connecticut Highlands in a relative
sense of course and in these areas the
geology has patterns that swirls around
as if it was it was taken in a butter
churn and swirled around or in a mixing
pot of doughy bread and that's exactly
what happened a hundred million years
prior to the rifting because connecticut
was the site of a great collision zone
looking at the geological map of
connecticut in a much larger context of
course geology knows no political
boundaries so we can extend the central
rift basin into central massachusetts
and it dies out right around the vermont
new hampshire border it was an
equivalent basin throughout most of New
Jersey one in Gettysburg and a series of
these cracks in the earth that failed to
develop into an oceanic rift however you
can see aside from those rift valleys
all these bright colors of greens and
purples and pinks and oranges these show
what's called the tectonic fabric a an
organization of the rocks which you can
almost imagine looks like someone took a
carpet and rocked it up and we're
looking at the great corrugations of
folds across the Appalachians and that's
what we think actually happened about
300 million years ago when what was
before in West Africa collided with what
was in North America so we had the
continents colliding at 300 million
years ago and tearing apart at 200
million years ago
so the supercontinent Pangaea existed
for that hundred million years and
during that time we would have expected
the sight of Canada to be truly a great
mountain range
something like the Himalayas if we
imagine an artist's conception of a
cross-section of the mountain range that
created the Appalachians you see all
those swirly patterns that you saw
expressed in the geological map of
Connecticut and New England and you can
almost imagine the movie that must have
occurred to produce the compression on
this cross-section and the landscape
that may have existed at that time so if
we now go globally outward and think
about what Pangaea looks like from the
perspective of its constituent elements
we can identify within its Pangaea base
map the ancient continent of North
America plus Greenland which is colored
in yellow and the ancient portion of
Africa which is colored in brown it's
called the West African a block or
kraton and various other pieces of
either South America or Central and
Southern Africa or India and Arctica
Australia as well as northern Europe and
Siberia and the Pangaea continent is
composed according to lots of geological
studies that have mapped the areas and
recognized compatibilities of geology
from one region to the other it is
composed of a series of building blocks
which did all collide and come together
and that is represented on this map by
these black regions with the red outline
those are the collision belts the great
mountain ranges that welded Pangaea if
we were to remove those we can now see
the building blocks that we would like
to put together in an arrangement that
existed prior to Pangaea and that is the
principal puzzle that I'm trying to
solve in my research where was West
Africa relative not only to North
America but relative to Amazonia
relative to the Congo block or Congo
[ __ ] relative to the southern African
bloc or called the Kalahari kraton there
are about 13 pieces in this puzzle and
since I've been doing puzzles since I
was before I could speak basically I
find this to be an extremely frustrating
puzzle because
with only 13 pieces how is it that we
cannot solve this so easily part of the
problem is that the picture on the
puzzle has been smeared has been partly
erased by subsequent geological events
and of course there is no box by which
we can see the answer to that puzzle as
well as a lot of these collisions have
tended to wear down the jigsaw locking
edges so it's not as simple as a jigsaw
puzzle but we are making some progress
with one piece at a time and the way we
are making that progress is by looking
at the magnetization of rocks and
realizing and appreciating the fact that
Earth's magnetic field which is
generated in the outer core of the Earth
from the liquid motions in the outer
core sends off field lines that go
through the Earth's surface and out to
space and back through the Earth's
surface and back into the interior of
the planet those field lines have a very
consistent relationship with the
geographic latitude of an observer
anywhere on the surface of the earth and
that relationship is such that
qualitatively if you are at the North
Pole the magnetic field lines are
straight down if you're at the South
Pole if you're standing at the South
Pole and looking upside down in this
figure
it looks like the field lines are coming
straight out of the ground going upward
and if you're on the equator the field
lines are tangential to the earth or
they look like they're going pointing
straight flat to the north and the angle
of intersection that vertical angle of
intersection between the Earth's surface
and these field lines very
systematically according to this formula
where I is that vertical angle we call
it the inclination and lambda stands for
the latitude on the surface of the earth
and a couple of trigonometric functions
and that allows us to take a rock sample
that formed many millions of years ago
understand that the geologic context in
which that sample was taken such that
for example if it's in a series of
sedimentary layers or volcanic layers we
know that those formed horizontally and
therefore they formed a nice
approximation of the Earth's surface
measure the magnetic direction in those
samples and therefore obtain this
inclination and from that we can infer
the latitudes
so this information is what we will use
to draw maps of the ancient world one
block at a time and many many ages at
one time so we need to go into the field
and collect a lot of rocks from a lot of
different ages I'm usually asked by lay
audiences how do you know where to go
and the answer is on all of those
geological maps that have each color for
the different rock types those are done
not only at the scale of the state of
Connecticut but also quadrangle scales
that can be very detailed maps and with
the information that's obtained
independently for dating the rocks we
can target where precisely we want to go
whether it's here in the Australian
outback or anywhere else in the world to
collect our samples when we do collect
our samples we can do it by using a
hammer but the more fun and interesting
way is to have a portable rock drill
which is essentially a chainsaw which
we've modified to have a diamond bit
drill bit on the end and we drill out a
little core sample and before we break
that core sample out from the rock we
can put it in a specialised orientation
device in this in the in the rock when
the sample is still inside and we can
measure both the horizontal azimuth of
that core and the vertical angle of that
core so we can orient this rock sample
that we collected whether in Australia
or anywhere else and then when we take
it back in and put it in my laboratory
we can use the computer to rotate those
directions into their field coordinates
the data look like this
and I won't belabor that point other
than to suggest that this is in fact
actually quite a complicated process
requiring some some art to being able to
understand the data that we obtain
especially in very old rocks my
laboratory where the measurements are
done looks like this and we have an
automatic system where each of these
little gray cylinders is a slice of one
of those cores that we drilled in the
field each one of these is placed on the
tray with an orientation mark which is
lined up with the 3d axes
our instrument and the sample is picked
up by a vacuum motor and carried held in
place by suction while the chain rotates
to a hole drops it down and just off the
picture here is a very very sensitive
magnetometer that can analyze the
magnetic strength not only in what you
might think is strongly magnetized
materials but also just everyday rocks
it was once said when these were first
invented in the 1970s this level of
magnetometer that you could measure the
magnetic direction in an apple corer and
then of course in Australia they
actually did that experiment and
measured the magnetic moment of an apple
corer so we can take rocks or any
materials that are not particularly
magnetic run-of-the-mill rocks that have
interesting and well-known geological
histories and measure their magnetic
directions obtain that vertical angle
and get the latitude so then when we try
to convert that into plotting the data
onto a map I'm going to take you through
a few minutes of this process we can
imagine looking down at the present
North Pole and I've taken away the other
continents for simplicity but here is a
stylized map of the North American
continent with the Great Lakes here
Hudson's Bay and if a rock formed
somewhere in the middle of North America
let's say close to Thunder Bay Ontario
and it was magnetized as it formed today
then the magnetic direction here would
be pointed like a compass needle toward
the present North Pole and that
relationship between the vertical angle
and the horizontal earth surface would
tell us the distance between the pole
and the site however if we look at
another rock which perhaps may be from
say the state of Wisconsin which is say
450 million years old and we take its
magnetic directions and we measure those
we can see not directions corresponding
to today's field but we see them in a
deflected in a different direction and
this is in fact a representation of the
actual data from 450 million year rocks
in Wisconsin and
we can through mathematical and
geometrical manipulation compute an
ancient position of the pole relative to
the site and that ancient position of
the pole is different from the present
North Pole and then the last step we
need to do is if we are identifying the
relative motion a relative position and
location of a site and a pole and if we
want to reconstruct the continent now to
its ancient latitude you just do a rigid
body rotation you can imagine holding my
arms as a rigid beam here and we're
going to shift the continent and this
magnetic pole shift it over until the
ancient magnetic pole reaches the
present North Pole and that's that same
shift that I applied to the continent
gives rise to a reconstructed position
of the continent which at that time lay
along the paleo equator and I've added
yes assuming always that the geomagnetic
dipole axis is parallel to the rotation
axis and that is a fascinating subject
of discussion all of the tests that we
have given that assumption have passed
to within about five percent accuracy
when we averaged over a few thousand
years and if of the time and if we are
willing to allow the freedom of not
knowing I priori whether the magnetic
pole that we're pointing to is a north
pole or a South Pole due to the fact
that the magnetic field reverses
occasionally thank you for that clear
point of clarification so we can say
from these directions that the ancestral
continent of North America lay along the
paleo equator we call it Loretta we know
it was joined with another continent of
northern Europe called baltica and that
is essentially how we go about doing
these reconstructions now I'm going to
take you back to the initial assembly of
fragments of North America back about
two billion years ago almost half of the
age of the earth and show you some of
the recent results from my laboratory
that have given rise to a hypothesis a
model that suggests that the current
algum of North America and for
Geographic reference that is Lake
Superior this is the state of Minnesota
the 49 parallel border with US and
Canada and then much of the Canadian
Shield is beautifully exposed exposed
ancient rock through Hudson's Bay and
over toward Yellowknife Northwest
Territories and what you see on this map
are a series of pieces if you want to
call them puzzle pieces you can
separated by these red and green zones
which are thought to be the sites of
vanished oceans that closed along with
the collision of all these blocks during
the interval of 1.9 to 1.8 billion years
ago previous to our work it was
recognized that these sutures owns these
tectonic suture zones were the sites of
vanished oceans that closed but the
previous of prior configuration which
even went as far as to name the oceans
Manny Quinn ocean Snowbird rift or ocean
didn't really know how wide those oceans
were so what my colleagues and I did a
synthesis in the last couple of years
where we are presenting a hypothesis
that is dealing with magnetic data and
what we're looking at now is an
animation of four hundred million years
of the Assembly of North American
continent the ages and millions of years
are shown up there and so they're going
by at a fairly rapid clip the the
fragments of North America are color
coded to match the magnetic data which
are appearing as circles if we have done
our job right those magnetic data are
plotting along the rotation axis and you
can see that the data are sparse and we
need to appeal to a lot of other
information to estimate where these
blocks were I'm going to point out one
data point there which is not ours but
it's an one from the literature which is
fascinating and needs to be revisited if
it's true then we will have to modify
the model but what you can see from this
diagram is that we are accounting for
all the blocks including for example
Wyoming which started off near where
Wisconsin is and moves over to join
Western Canada and then Westar
Canada and Greenland assemble first and
then finally the the portion of eastern
Canada comes in on the side at the end
and from this history of 400 million
years we have at least a working model
now for the creation of the North
American continent and this take took a
lot of organization and there's special
software to be able to do this and I'm
sure it's wrong in many ways but I'm
very excited that we now have at least a
template for further investigations
we've taken this now globally and the
fragments of North America now from time
interval of 2100 million years
moving forward in time the fragments of
North America are plotted in the
northern hemisphere and and upside down
in your orientation for reasons we think
that we have various reasons to suggest
that there was in northern hemisphere at
the time those are shown in yellow and
the other blocks of the world are
color-coded according to what continent
they form in now and we can just imagine
the millions of years going by as the
current continents assemble for the
first time so we think a J offshore of
northern Canada was were the fragments
of what would eventually become Siberia
portions of Australia shown in blue
still yet to come together portions of
South America in light green and Africa
in red India in purple still and Asian
bloc's in purple northern India southern
India far away from each other once
again this kind of model is tied loosely
by a series of data which are being
plotted in the northern hemisphere there
there's a lot of room for improvement
but I'm what I'm most excited about is
for the first time our community is
being able to assemble some templates by
which we can really look and set up a
global hypothesis for some of these
motions right this can go on for another
400 million years but I think we should
move along
one of the key aspects of this interval
of time in what we think was the
Assembly of the Earth's first
supercontinent about 1.8 to 1.6 billion
years ago which has been called nuna
that supercontinent is the assembly and
the breakup of that supercontinent is
known globally as as occurring during a
time of many many mineral resources and
another part of the project that I'm
very excited about is that we in
addition to our magnetic results and our
simple polygons that we're moving around
the surface of the earth we are also
integrating our work with extensive
databases of the ages of rocks and
mineral deposits and if you're a mineral
expert you'll recognize that nickel and
copper and platinum group elements go
together that gold and copper sometimes
go together
iron oxide copper gold volcano genic
massive sulfide deposits lode gold
unconformity uranium Mississippi Valley
type lead zinc sediment set X
sedimentary copper all of these now can
potentially be mapped and charted and
move around with our grid to be able to
see where these deposits formed not on
today's present grid but also but more
importantly on the paleo grids and what
was the tectonic environment and these
black symbols here are representations
of where we think the ancient plate
boundaries were that we're accommodating
these continental motions so I'm very
excited about this as an exploration
tool for mineral deposits moving forward
in time and we will see this theme
recurring as we think about long-term
sustainability of our civilization in
fact I think many of you may have
thought that if I'm talking about
projecting continental motions far into
the future that that would have our
bearing on the future of humankind
actually I think the more important
aspect of our bearing on humankind is
that the work we're doing in the ancient
earth to be able to locate many of these
mineral resources so finally we will go
to the future and we will talk about
this paper that to which Tom referred
the in his introduction
and that is the question of whether
there will be another supercontinent and
we certainly have enough time left over
to assemble new continents a part of the
next supercontinent is already being
created in the amalgam which is eastern
Asia India has collided with Asia
already Australia is moving north and
shows no signs of stopping as it plows
through New Guinea and ultimately the
Philippines and ultimately Taiwan and
Japan to collide with eastern Siberia
but what's less understood is whether as
a thought experiment whether we might
expect the West the current westward
motion of the Americas to continue all
the way across the Pacific and join Asia
from from that direction or whether we
expect the Atlantic Ocean to stop
spreading and to turn around and become
another collision zone in an accordion
type of fashion of supercontinent cycle
time cycle or in our paper we made the
the alternative suggestion that the
Americas have moved as far west as
they're going to move and thereafter are
only going to move north South Australia
we know has moved as far east as it's
going to move and has already begun
moving north and to explain the details
of this would require another hour but
so I won't I won't go through that but
let's I one point I want to make is that
this captured media attention because of
the speculation and the broad thinking
in terms of what could the world look
like 50 to 100 of 250 million years ago
but in reality the disclaimer is that
that is all idle speculation and is not
in fact science if you yes it's a
prediction but if you set up an
experiment that you need to wait 150
million years to see if it's verified
it's technically not really a scientific
hypothesis it was useful however as a
thought experiment because it was our
way of relating to people what we did
find which was science which was a
relationship between three ancient
supercontinents and the two transitions
between those ancient supercontinents
where we did find motion that would be
akin to the Atlantic stopping opening
and akin to the Americas moving
north-south and not going any further
west
and not turning around to the east but
again to explain that in detail would
require rather advanced topics so I'll
leave it there for now but just for your
amusement we can see according to our
model 150 million years into the future
Australia arriving and crunching up the
rest of eastern Asia and our
long-awaited partners in South America
joining us here in Connecticut and so
this was the Amasia
model that it's not science it literally
took me about three minutes to
arbitrarily put these maps together but
they are a good way of thinking about
where we sit relative to a long
succession of super continents that may
be coming and going and the work that we
were doing on the ancient supercontinent
I think is art that is actually
scientifically testable as hypothesis so
this did make a media splash just about
two years ago this week my two of my
graduate students were my co-authors
they were first and second author and
they were able to handle all the media
frenzy New York Times did a very good
job and suggested now we're looking down
at the South Pole with both the current
grid of continents and the future motion
of closure of the Arctic Ocean
the ancient location of the center of
Pangaea off on the equator underneath
Africa and the three predictions that we
set up were that either the next Pangaea
would form back where the old one was or
would go the all the other side or we
would have this intermediate one in
between now if any of you have done
anything that has captured media
attention you can take all of these
posts and and find your harshest critics
on the internet so we have one critic
who suggested that some PhD student got
a five-year grant and $100,000 salary
per year for the study's findings I
think we're still striving to give our
PhD students $100,000 a year
far from it so we have that criticism we
have another criticism from from this
gentleman who
who was just flabbergasted at the
paucity of intelligence to think that
such in elegance could arise from Yale
University but then I think he kind of
gives himself a little discredit by
suggesting the thermodynamics second law
insist that could not happen and so
anyway you really get a good reality
check on on the freight the societal
framework of your science when you
actually do make a media splash however
there are some more positive assessments
and I'm always going to be grateful for
for this lady who has rendered her
actually rather quite quite positive
opinion about the work okay so we
continue to make progress in these past
and future motions and now I want to
return to the final aspect of the talk
which is thinking now about the billions
of years of evolutionary history and
Taconic history of the earth thinking
about where humans fit in in this all so
we will return to the timescale and
remember that humans come on the scene
in a very broad sense with our
australopithecines ancestors at 8:10
p.m. actually on the same kind of
calendar year analogy time scale the
countdown the New Year's Eve countdown
would actually go 150 years per second
so if you if you would allow me it would
go something like Gutenberg Renaissance
enlightenment industrial happy new years
right so 150 years a second and so I
gave you a pole at the beginning of the
the lecture of fifty thousand years into
the future because fifty thousand years
ago is according to some anthropologists
about the time when we started to really
emerge from our more primal roots
developing some music by that time
starting to work our way towards
certainly control the fire to work our
way towards domestication a little early
before that but so fifty thousand
years into the future is enough time to
really think about well this this could
be a really long-term prospect for
thinking about the human race and I'll
now register some of my own opinions
about these six possibilities the first
one the natural extinction by meteor
impacts or supernova explosion I think
the chances geologically speaking the
chances of that are very small on a
50,000 year time scale in terms of
manmade extinction this is of course a
real possibility and but I would like to
and to pursue a more optimistic agenda
than that when I think about my own you
know life's goals and so forth trans
religious apocalypse and et
civilizations I personally don't
subscribe to and then these these these
two options for whether humans are going
to survive either confined to the solar
system or confined into deep expanding
into deep space a la Star Trek actually
the nearest star is about four or so
light-years away there are planets
orbiting around stars that are that are
within say ten light-years from us but
the speed of light is so fast that for
us to actually propel a vehicle to get
there would take really really long time
and I don't think fifty thousand years
is enough time to do it so really when
we think about fifty thousand years my
hope is that we will try to find
solutions that really exist on earth
okay we can talk about terraforming Mars
and so forth but that's very expensive
and I think we really should have our
agenda on sustaining ourselves on the
earth and if we think now in terms of
human history from on the order of tens
of thousands of years ago to the present
and an estimate that I found somewhere
on the web in terms of which I tried to
fact-check a little bit and seems
reasonable of human population going
from 0 up to 7 billion which we just
surpassed basically it's a very very
slow steady rise until the Industrial
Revolution when things take off clearly
it's the unlocking of what some of my
colleagues have called nature's
treasure trove of of the consequences of
four billion years of tectonic mixing
and concentrating some elements not only
in terms of mineral resources but also
of course our fossil fuels that is
allowing us to make technological
advances and enjoy really unprecedented
levels of prosperity globally and has
allowed this population expansion to
happen and so we might think that a
prior to that technological development
the more or less sustainable population
population on earth would be on the
order of a hundred million people okay
the question is as we think about moving
far into the future looking at a very
very broad timeline another timeline
from left to right several thousand
years from now people will look back at
us and say this was the oil age and that
oil age is a little blip all right will
the far side of that blip be reflected
in a precipitous decline in human
population back to the sustainable level
I don't know or will our engineers save
us and harness renewable energies and
recycle resources to be able to sustain
us in the long term you may have heard
about Peak Oil there's a lot of
discussion about Peak Oil this is one
rendition that comes from an
introductory textbook that I use and
this would be a more pessimistic view
that we're already actually past the
peak others will say that the peak won't
come until another hundred years from
now or 200 years but regardless of when
you think pink what peak oil will be
when you stand back on a ten thousand
year timeline the age of oil is in fact
a little spike and I think there's
there's no one who would argue with that
because oil just doesn't continue down
at depth forever into the earth so let's
talk about where those limited resources
lie relative to what we might consider
the the economic growth of the planet
and if the economic growth is tied at
all to the consumption of resources we
can consider several projections into
the future
first we can look at and I am NOT an
economist and I know there's many
degrees of freedom in very very simple
models that I created with excel in the
last few days
so this is not fancy by any means but
its simplicity is actually an advantage
because I think I can understand the
math that goes into this so we'll start
out with a level of 1 for today's both
availability of resources and today's
current consumption level and let's
suppose that annual economic growth or
economic growth in general corresponds
with a degree of consumption of
resources and it may not be a perfect
fit but it would be something along
those lines if you were an economist and
you said let's do 3 percent annual
growth that's moderately healthy economy
it's not something that you certainly
wouldn't be satisfied with it if you
were a leader in the People's Republic
of China where you'd be looking for more
like 5 or 10% annual growth but it's a
healthy economy but by the timeline of a
hundred years from now that kind of
consumption vastly outstrips
any model of the available resources the
ideally optimistic endowment is the was
a I put as an upper limit where we
continue to find an equivalent of
resources commensurate with what we've
used already every hundred years ok
every hundred years in the future we
find the equivalent of what we've
already are using right now and I call
that ideally optimistic you could maybe
have it slightly more we could have a
more cyclical endowment of resources
that awaits us for through further
exploration and this is actually just a
sine wave and you'll see that later on
or you can have a dwindling endowment of
resources and of course some resources
will follow more or less the optimistic
level some will be more cyclical and
some will be dwindling I heard a
fascinating talk yesterday by Tom Gradle
on the question of will metal resources
become unaffordable to us in the near
future and I think his assessment was
that the answer for some of those is yes
we can see that a 1% annual growth also
outstrips the available resources
according to any of these very simple
models on the order of two hundred years
but this 0.5 percent annual growth is
getting able to to respond to those what
if instead though we go to a thousand
years into the future
well now the 3 percent and the 1 4
and the point five percent annual growth
are all zooming up with that kind of
curve that expands almost to infinity
the ideally optimistic endowment carries
on but it's not nearly enough to keep up
with 0.5 percent annual growth cyclical
endowment keeps going on very very low
and dwindling endowment goes to zero you
could have a model which I think would
be realistic for many resources
somewhere in between which would come up
to some asymptotic value and then maybe
be sick Euler at some level in between
this ideally optimistic model and
another cyclical model but let's now
continue on the 50,000 year time scale
which I was asking you about with the
pole at the beginning of the lecture now
we have with even our most ideally
optimistic endowment even that point one
percent annual growth has far
outstripped the available resources
within five thousand years and by even
about thirty thousand years in the
future even 0.02 percent annual growth
vastly outstrips the available resources
so you can see with these kinds of
curves that any kind of compound
compounding annual growth will at some
point in time in the distant future lead
to a curve of that function relative to
resources which are ultimately limited
on the earth so this leads to the
conjecture that truly long term
sustainability at any time scale into
the future equals zero percent not 0.02
percent not 0.01 strictly zero percent
economic growth all right and
commensurate with that is that because
resources are limited we can't just
throw them away we have to begin to
co-adapted our global environment and
move on a path toward nearly a hundred
percent resource recycling now so that
may be sobering news and it could be
very sobering news if we return to the
thought of us here at our New Year's Eve
party because as we count down the the
hundred fifty years every second toward
the future we think well fifty thousand
years from now on this kind of timescale
is not that far in the future
and if we're thinking about maybe a
long-term agenda of the human race if
you're an optimist and you'd like to see
some sort of sustainable development I
think we it's just a matter of time
before we migrate from the current
growth based economy until a Newton into
a new model which is essentially
recognizing that the only sustainability
in the long run is is flatlining and
recycling so with that I am happy to
entertain your questions and I thank you
for your participation